hi this is Sal Khan of the Khan Academy
and I'm super excited about all of y'all
joining us on this conversation on
google+ and first I want to introduce
the folks we're going to be directly
involved in this conversation i'll start
with dar she'll and if everyone can
introduce aware they're from and what
they do for a living hi I'm da Silva i
am from East Greenwich Rhode Island I
work at the Rocky Hill School as the
library and technology into later thanks
for joining us and we have Eric hey
everyone my name is Eric gray wow I'm
from Seattle Washington and I'm a senior
at monroe high school excellent and Matt
hello I am Matt Gardner I'm a PhD
student at carnegie mellon university in
pittsburgh pennsylvania focusing on
machine learning and language
technologies also and finally Neal um hi
this is Neil hello everyone I'm
associate professor of medicine and
director of education technology at the
cleveland clinic lerner college of
medicine I'm also the founder of this
Google+ community and very excited to be
here awesome so what i thought i would
do i'll just kind of talk a little bit
about about what we're here for and then
really just open it up and as as
promised this is really more about a
conversation everyone on on this the
Hangout has has some questions but for
myself but I hope that it we all kind of
give feedback and and and really make
make headway on some of these ideas but
as was talked about when we decide to
launch this we want to talk about
education the future of education what
is education and I'll throw out some
some some of the big ideas that that we
can kind of think about as we go through
this conversation one is one is is let's
try to let's try to blank slate things
as much as we can that so much of the
education conversation is around Oh what
should high school be what should
college be what should a college diploma
high school diploma but and I think
there's an opportunity for us to take a
step back so well even these these
notions of high school or middle school
or college these are human created
constructs and and can we can we maybe
reham
imagine what these things could be or
where they might go I think there's the
idea of obviously Khan Academy we exist
virtually but one thing that we always
talk about that I always talk about is
this isn't a an issue of a virtual
versus physical this is a verte this is
a at least in my mind and although i'd
love to hear other people's thoughts
about it of a virtual and physical and
trying to leverage the best of both
worlds of having computers and
technology and also teachers and mentors
and peers and and and and so I'd like to
think about that as we have this
conversation and then the last pieces
which is obviously an important part of
education is credentialing what what is
a credential what's the nature of it
what are good what's good about existing
credentials what's not working a cost
what and where where could this go or
and you know what what's the ideal and
also what's practical what's likely to
happen based on kind of the dynamics in
the world today so with that kind of
just overlay of things to think about
over the neck or the course this
conversation I'd love to open it up i'll
start with our shell I believe you I
believe you have a question yes um well
my first question is um what do you
think the greatest innovation in
educational technology will be within
the next five to ten years the greatest
innovation in education technology the
next five to ten years and I'll take my
stab and I'm curious to hear hear what
other people think I'm biased i think
it's this thing called conic no I'm
kidding I'm kidding I think it's the
general idea and you know once and this
is something i would say these aren't
new ideas that if you went you know 400
years ago and you said what's the ideal
education you would have said oh it's
someone having a really awesome personal
tutor or maybe several personal tutors
this is what you know princes had 400
years ago they would have an army of
personal tutors one to make sure the
Prince can write another one that makes
sure he's building his leadership skills
another person making sure that they can
appreciate art etc and and the value of
the well there's many values of the
personal tutor but i guess the prime one
is that the tutor adapts to the student
you know today our model is one much
more of the student having to adapt to
the crew
the curriculums going in at a face and
that the student has to slow down speed
up sometimes their loss sometimes
there's more so I think I think what's
exciting about the next five years is
that the promise of personalized
education which has been that forever
you know famously Steve Jobs you the
Macintosh of the personal computer as a
treadmill for the mind and people have
always been talking about computers is a
way to personalize it and whatever else
I think all of the ingredients have
finally come in place where over the
next five or ten years i hope i hope
Khan Academy is part of this we can
really personalize for the individual
student and I think if we really
personalize we can really cater to
exactly the misconception that a student
has exactly where they are we can keep
them engaged we can use game mechanics
and community and points and badges
whatever to keep them extrinsically
motivated and also we can make the
exercises themselves interesting so that
you actually want to know the answers
you're intrinsically motivated I hope in
United office will be five years 10
years 15 years we get to a world that
are where we see that our expectations
for learners of all ages you know right
now we expect a seventh or eighth grader
to have you know know a little bit of
basic algebra a little bit you know
negative numbers exponents I think the
human mind once it's motivated by
something once it's personalized could
learn an order of magnitude faster and
so we'll have a bunch of middle school
kids you know writing writing great
works of fiction and studying quantum
mechanics I don't know it's gonna be
five years but but that's that's
something like that is my hope I don't
know what what's your thoughts on that
dar she'll um I agree with you in the
point that on personalized education
seems to be where it is and should be
going within one to one i pad programs
etc our one to one technology programs
bring your own device etc we have made
many more avenues for students to be
able to follow their own interest and
see where they're wanting to learn will
take them hell yeah ya know completely
completely agree any other thoughts you
know I was thinking about this and you
I love mastery-based progression through
the curriculum a total believer in that
I was wondering what your thoughts are
on the risks of this and what I mean is
suppose you have a kid and some
overzealous parents you know instead of
soccer moms we have Khan Academy dads
and they drive their kids through a very
rapid progression you know that this you
could see this happening with certain
communities and we have a risk I think
of having these uni-dimensional Doogie
Howser's in the future is that a risk
how do you manage that and what are your
thoughts it's it's a very real risk it's
you know i have very conflicted feelings
about it it's you know one I I don't
think this is purely a risk of the world
you know of online ad or Khan Academy
know this phenomenon has existed as long
as there have been Tiger parents this is
this this is this phenomenon it's been
around and you always there is at risk
of you know the kid it's just you know
being forced to learn things maybe not
even learning it the right way
memorizing more you know maybe not
loving the subject because they're being
forced to do it so so it's not ideal by
any stretch of the imagination but at
the same time you know sometimes those
kids disproportionately do end up doing
alright you know I end up having a very
binary outcome you know maybe eighty
percent of them end to end up you know
going and getting a doctorate in
something or becoming a doctor an
engineer or something the other twenty
percent end up becoming depressed and I
see it somewhat jokingly but I I know
people that you know if they didn't get
it to the ultra success they end up
becoming depressed and and disaffected
and unhappy with with life and that's
obviously not good and even when they do
become wildly successful or you know are
quite successful they become
professionals they might be missing some
of you know the the imagination or the
creativity that I personally think we
all have in us it's just you know if
you're if you're just being forced down
a certain Road it could be lost so I
think some of some of you know
RN at Khan Academy I think this is true
of all anyone trying to be part of the
education equation I think we have to
prioritize the other parts of the
learning experience of the socialization
experience you know and it's tough
because even in traditional schools you
know if I were to run a very progressive
school that has you know drama and has
ardh and the kids are doing projects
that's great and I believe in that I you
know one day if the kids the school my
kids go to I want it to be mostly that I
want it to be conversations but at the
end of the day if there's a test and the
test isn't measuring any of this other
stuff and the test is what's determining
which direction the kid you know who
gets the who gets the the opportunity
who doesn't then the test is what
everyone starts preparing for and so I
think the key and this to start you know
we can go deeper on the credentialing
conversation here is that the
credentialing architecture whatever it
is the transcripts the grades the
degrees they need to start appreciating
these other things and it's harder
because it's harder to measure it's easy
to give some 150 multiple choice
questions and how many you got right
it's much harder to you know give
someone feedback on their imagination or
the creativity or there but I think I
think it's doable I you know I think
here again the internet I viewed as a
continent conduit for humanizing things
so you know before I write a paper I'd
only get feedback from my teacher and
you know and i usually don't get a
chance to work on it again i can imagine
in five or ten years you write something
it becomes part of your portfolio online
and you get feedback from folks and
different people's feedback will be
weighted based on their reputation and
so that you can have a really good
measure of your creative works i could
imagine a system where you get feedback
on you know you're working with your
peers you get feedback on how good of a
explainer you are so you know i think it
it's kind of hell it's it's good for a
parent to be interested and for a parent
to in a healthy way push their their
child's a little bit but i would like to
see the metric on which they're being
pushed yes it's fine you've learned to
factor a polynomial or whatever else but
also hey you know you're really high on
that level but you're not getting you
know you're you need to do more these
creative art projects and you know look
a lot a lot of people say that this work
is very derivative you should
you should think more out of the box or
you know you're doing really good on
those two dimensions but look you need
more reputation points on how good of an
explainer you are why don't you work on
this hey you got some feedback that your
empathy is a two out of five but well
let's think about what you could do to
get your empathy to be a 4 out of 5 you
know these aren't these aren't easy
things to tackle but but hopefully in
the system's themselves and in the
school's themselves we can start to
architect some of that and then a lot of
it I think is is communication you know
I think it's funny because I think
university admissions especially elite
universities have been trying to do this
where they look at students
extracurriculars and then they look at
your essay and they look at leadership
but every time they add a new thing to
the application the kids just become
focused on that innate it almost ruins
the and you even have you have this
happening at higher education as well
where higher education is this very you
know it should be this pure intellectual
journey or somewhat pure but a lot of
students are thinking about hey am I
going to get an interview with goldman
sachs and because of that they are you
know they're not viewing the philosophy
class the way they should be there just
thinking about the grade not thinking
about the philosophy so it's a hard
question it's not a new question I think
online will exacerbate some of the
problems but it might offer solutions
for for someone as well oh yeah yeah if
I can share some insight especially
coming from the perspective of a high
school student you know we put so much
emphasis on AP courses s80 scores and
right now I'm going through the
application process or universities and
of course there's a lot of problems that
especially in our communities in our
society we have because of this emphasis
I think one way we can come back this is
due personalization of Education of
course with the Khan Academy which
recently was revamped to have to have
personalized features to tell you where
your educational gaps are but also may
be utilizing social media to look at
what a person's interests is and guiding
it that student towards things that
they're interested in and if we can
create some kind of portfolio of that
that would definitely be a more useful
metric for evaluating some of these
personalities somebody's intellect
rather than looking at just numbers on a
sheet of paper so I think
personalization in education is
definitely something that we can
utilized to help solve this problem let
me ask a question Eric I mean exact you
are you're in the middle of it you're
applying I mean what are your what what
do you you know from your vantage point
you're in the system which what's your
viewpoints like what do you think is
working well what do you think is you
know because of the way the system is
architected you think these things are
happening well in your life you're
developing the right elements and what
are you what are you frustrated by uh I
think one of the things that's really
facilitating me helping me is the amount
of resources that are out there and that
are increasing and the availability of
people to push you towards those like if
you're interested in academics of course
there are opportunities for you whether
you take AP courses go to an honours
track and pursue different
extracurricular activities those are
definitely working well but I would
agree that evaluation is where it falls
short I mean taking the s80 which judges
for example ESAT which judges only on
three different subjects that wouldn't
that may work well for some people who
are interested in specific careers such
as mathematics or writing but how can we
evaluate people who are more interested
in the arts the humanities different
subjects like that and I think that's
really where it falls short and
especially in the college application
process colleges have a hard time of
judging what the personality of their
applicants I like I mean through a 650
where the essay a few more essays and
just some data you can't really make an
a very good guess approximation of what
extreme is like what the personality is
and how they're going to fit into a
university so there are gaps in the
evaluation system that I think that we
as a society need to work on yeah and do
you feel like you have a lot of time to
work on creative things I definitely do
not think that I would have I would
appreciate I mean I take classes at the
high school I also take classes at the
Community College and on top of
extracurricular activity there's so much
doing the day but i really want to
pursue other things that I haven't
interested in like learning languages or
learning different forms of art and as a
high school straight you don't always
get time to pursue all of those
interests ya know completely agree and
for whatever it's worth my two cents on
you know the application process which I
know is probably one the most stressful
that is in competition probably with
your wedding for the most
period of life but the the if anything
you can to document your creativity
record a youtube video whatever it might
be send it in I think as you said that
you know that would add so much more
than the 650 word essay and and yeah so
but good luck with that thank you up
Matt you you you have any questions or
thoughts yeah i guess going back to
something we talked about earlier my
main question maybe reflects my bias a
little bit as a computer science student
but i wonder how you can scale
personalized learning so khan academy if
you're a particular kind of learner and
you want to learn k through 12 math I
think Khan Academy does a pretty good
job at letting you do personalized
learning but how did how do you scale it
to other kinds of students other
subjects more advanced math no yeah ya
know this this is a good question and
you know I we don't know all the answers
at Khan Academy our sense is you're
absolutely right if there's a motivated
individual that shows up at the side at
whatever age you know old enough to kind
of interface with the side and they want
to learn math Khan Academy does a pretty
good job and although I think there's a
million things that we could do to
improve it but what do you do about the
kid who thinks that they're not good at
math or it's not and that's why we do
view and even for the kid who thinks
that they're good at math and is
motivated that's where the physical
classroom really matters and you know
with the scale in my mind when a lot of
times people talk about scale they
usually know maybe this is without
humans but there's already a really
incredible infrastructure in place
called the school system that where
there are these you know adults were you
know the great majority of them care
nothing more than trying to make sure
that the kids learn and so you know when
we think about the scale problem we say
well in a classroom where you do have a
teacher and you do have peers what what
can that due to take things to another
level so Khan Academy you know for the
student who's just not you know who's
not nine years old and dying to learn
algebra Khan Academy will do the best
weekend we'll try to motivate them as
well as we can through the software we
could test it and all that but the ideal
is you get into a physical classroom
where the teacher is there to mentor
teacher there's two guy teacher can and
this and there's an art here too
we're learning this to observing
different classroom there's an art to
setting the culture of the room
correctly when this is hugely dependent
on the teacher and then many many times
the peers so that it is a culture of
exploration a culture where failures
okay it's a culture of collaboration
it's a culture where you can help each
other that goes a long long way you know
if you if you take almost any child and
you insert them into a room where the
culture is already established and the
culture is around learning the culture
is about discovery the culture is about
helping each other they have access to
mentors almost any child I believe will
adopt that culture that's just the way
we are human beings now if you take if
you the opposite you take a kid who's
altra motivated and you put him or her
into a culture that's very broken and
that you know learning is there's a
stigma around it and there's not a lot
of support than the opposite the
opposite might happen so I think the
culture in the classroom is an important
thing and we haven't figured it out but
we started to see a lot of classrooms
that are using Khan Academy as part of
what they do to to help there in terms
of other subjects you know writing is
one where you know we briefly touched on
it but but you know writing is an
environment where i could imagine it
will you could still use technology but
it's not going to be like oh you did
this essay right or wrong it'll be you
submitted it you get peer feedback you
know your computer science PhD so I you
know I think there is some work in
artificial intelligence to do a first
pass or also use that to to even rate
Raiders you know you know how consistent
is this I mean there's there's and I
know EDX the MIT and Harvard initiative
has has has been working on doing some
work there you know we've talked a fair
Lee prominent artificial intelligence
researcher who believes that there's a
lot of AI that's ready to be used where
you could start approaching some type of
Socratic dialogue so so you know there's
all sorts of crazy things out there I
don't think this is going to be solved
tomorrow that's why it's incredibly I
think what kind of kept me definitely
can do or say in the next five years is
definitely we can give the core scaffold
in most areas so whether it's k through
12 math but even in middle school math
there's you know that you could go on
you could do some proofs you could do
some hands-on things you can do some
simulations that Khan Academy might not
be able to address
but we'll be able to do the scaffold the
core you know the core idea is that you
should know about it's the same thing
with writing you know we might we might
have some type of pure based thing in
five years but we'll definitely have
some type of grammar thing its grammar
is very mathematical very easy higher
mathematics I could imagine no we can do
the core of say differential equations
but you really haven't learned to French
equations unless you're applying
differential equations to model
phenomenon to model fluid dynamics
whatever it might be and so that's what
the hopefully the classroom or the
laboratory will focus on you know Khan
Academy's computer science platform
already I think goes a lot in that
direction it's gotten a lot of Khan
Academy's for lack of a better word core
learning but then you know we did this
computer science to start to experiment
with students creating things saving
them in their portfolio getting peer
feedback so you know a short the long
answer way of saying i'll never say
there's something that's completely
beyond the realm of what we're doing it
might take 500 years to get there but
we're going to keep trying to push the
envelope but the beauty is is it's not
an either/or I never wanted to set this
up as a conversation of light because
that it's just never it's not not going
to be possible there's a computer is
never going to be able to replicate what
you can get from an environment with
other other human beings right so I
guess I wonder if you've considered
making Khan Academy more of a platform
where users can submit educational
content maybe improve the knowledge map
with moderation or like with moderators
making sure it's okay and yeah if that's
a feasible way to scale and quicker into
other subjects this is another these are
excellent questions this is this is this
is something that I struggled with as
early as 2005 when but this is before
Khan Academy even had any videos and I
was just working on exercises and then
when I started making some videos is
actually my first impulse was hey I made
the prototype why don't you my friends
helped me on this or why don't I try to
find other folks and I was just some
crazy guy operating out of a closet no
one wanted to ever it's like oh that's
cute what you're doing I keep doing it
and and so at some point at least in the
getting I was just like oh well gee all
right well I like doing this let me keep
going and and all the way until today
you know even on our organization we're
always having this debate of to what
degree should we become a platform for
everyone to make content or to what
degree should it should be a fairly
heavily curated collection of things and
and you know the the arguments on either
side the curated collection on things
it's like look you know Khan Academy
means something to people now it means
that they're going to hopefully and it's
not perfect but hopefully they're going
to get something that they connect with
it feels human they get a lot of
practice it's personalized if you had a
bunch of you know if it was if it was
the Wild West if it was just you know
kind of random videos and everyone
uploaded well then that could be that
could be a very inconsistent experience
there could there probably be some gems
in there but for every gem you might
have to go through nine things that
might be pretty discouraging or so how
do you how do you figure that out and
that might that's on the videos that's
on the exercises you can do peer
reputation thing so we're we're settling
I think is is and I'd love to get all of
your feedback on this is we are
definitely going to try to create our
curated Khan Academy experience that is
you know it's not but it's not just me
making the content it's not just people
in house with our with our question
writers right now we have about 20
teachers researchers around the country
we're always looking for more if you're
interested in helping out who are
helping us write the sum of the question
content who are starting to write
simulations the math department of
Phillips Andover is starting to help
with work with us on the calculus items
to me really make sure it's it's up to
their standard on the platform side what
you're going to see over the next i
would say about six months is we've some
very reputable partners these are
well-known high schools well-known
universities well-known museums other
institutions are going to create their
own area on Khan Academy that they're
going to curate and and it's kind of
going to be under their brand but that's
still pretty heavily curated and and I
and so it's we hope over time to move
more in the direction
almost anyone can create things on the
site I know what your thoughts are there
I just wonder if if machine learning
could tame the wild west that you were
afraid of that some smart algorithms
could couldn't at least be a part of
your curation yeah I think it's
definitely possible and we'd love you
know see it we're serious about we'd
love to explore any if there is a way to
do that well I mean we'd be very open to
it so salad a follow up to that
responding to Matt's question and
wondering about the role of the educator
of the future and one thought I have is
we have these fabulous open education
resources like Khan Academy but each
teacher you know one of the things they
want to do is create pretty customized
learning plans based on their learning
objectives and you could see now a lot
of these tools crowding up that lets you
take bits of videos from difference open
sources splice them together and
intersperse them with questions but
these are created by the individual
teacher for their class and do you see
this as one of the skills that educators
of the future are going to need and what
is their role and how do we get them on
board yeah well you know I think that's
I think the role that you're describing
is as the the teacher being the curator
of the resources that that role has been
teachers had that's been one of the
roles that they've been playing for as
long as they've been teachers you know
even in a text book you know you know
the teach you never start on page one in
a classroom and go straight through the
teacher will say okay we're starting
chapter three we're going to skip this
section then we're gonna go to chapter 7
you know if they have a couple of books
they're going to switch between the
books and now with all the online
resources you do see a lot of teachers
saying oh well you know I like that part
from Khan Academy I oh I found this
interesting thing that nASA has on their
site let me let me throw that in the mix
and and I think that's great and you
know to Matt's point we hope in the next
few years we can we can we will allow
for what we would call custom missions
Khan Academy and I'll talk a second what
missions ours is something we're gonna
launch in in a few weeks where it is a
teacher can collect these things that
that he or she cares about and they need
to achieve it uh the the balance that
we're trying to keep it khanacademy
though is you know we don't want to
compromise the personalized learning
aspect of it so you know kind of Kevin
can be used however someone wants to use
it and we were happy someone uses in any
way they want if you know if they're
they if they telling everyone to watch
the same things or do the same exercise
on a given night that's not our ideal
that's not personalized learning or it's
not mastery-based learning but it's
still better you know it's they're still
able to use the resources and hopefully
it'll bring people into this this
personalized a narrative but when we
make the tools we want to at least push
people to the personalization we want to
nudge that like it's nice for everyone
to be you know sometimes in a classroom
it is it does make sense for everyone to
do the same thing to have an exact
shared experience let's all have this
conversation together let's all do this
project but what we want to do is is so
instead of describing it as a as a
pacing guide or a lesson plan we would
want it much more of like here are the
things that you want your student to
achieve and you can you as the teacher
can define those things we will have
some pre created ones you know actually
this is what we're going to launch in
the next few weeks you know common fifth
grade common core math sixth grade
common core math this is a goal once you
do it then the system is going to try to
personalize for that but I could imagine
in the future you might have a you know
a mission around I don't know what you
teach at the med school you teach
basically all of a lot of medicine
clinical okay you teach all of that is
all of clinical medicine so so you could
make your own your own missions where
you're collecting content from Khan
Academy maybe other resources maybe you
create your own quizzes and that you can
create that mission assign it to your
students and then the students will be
able to do that and you'll get all the
dashboards that that that you being able
to create that personalized mission I
think that we're still a couple of years
out because we frankly haven't even
figured out the missions where we create
it or close partner of ours creates it
but but that's that's the direction but
you know you my sense of the teacher of
the
future what what they're going to be
spending a lot more time doing I think
there's going to be it's going to be a
lot more around actually I mean you
probably even appreciate this as a
physician it's you know my wife's a
physician and it's not just about
Diagnostics it's about like how do you
change the mindset of the patient so
that you know a lot of the patients by
my wife sees they could become a lot
better if they took the pills on time or
if they modify their diet and the right
way or the lifestyle in the right way
and and and you know a lot of I talked
to Wendy Kopp of Teach for America and
she would mention mentioning to me that
the teachers who are really moving the
dial with students are the ones that are
able to change the students mindsets
they're not necessarily the best
lectures and not necessarily the PhDs
where they can change the minds that
they can change the students mindset
from one of a teacher tell me what to do
next 20 this is my goal I'm going to try
to reach it and the teacher and my peers
are here to help me so I think that the
teacher of the future is I think the
role of the teacher in the future one I
it's not going just be one teacher in a
room of 30 i think it could be two
teachers in a room of 63 teachers in a
room of 90 same ratio the lower the
better but it's it's a collaborative
thing and much more of a teacher's time
is having one one-on-one conversations
with students really trying to figure
out where they are really motivating
them trying to change their mindset and
and and then you know doing really fun
simulations and projects and games and
you know I it's easy for me to say this
but it's hard to do I would say it's
much harder it's much harder to do an
open-ended exploration with a handful of
students especially if it's truly
open-ended it's not a you know it's not
a glue this year and do you know paint
this year it's a let's try to find the
answer to this and we might succeed or
we might fail and it might it won't just
be over the course until the bell rings
55 minutes it'll be list this two weeks
let's invest and let's dig deep into
this this one thing and it's really hard
to do that when it you know different
kids are different levels and but but I
think that's really interesting I think
sitting down and trying to chat with
every student and try to think about
what's going on in his or her life and
and and having them think about you know
you talked a little bit about the tiger
parents and you know they're putting a
lot of pressure on their kids
and any extreme is unhealthy but at
least those kids are getting there
getting that information boy this
academics matters to me if I want to
reach out come a B or C if I want to be
like that person or that person well a
lot of students are missing that in
their life they they might not even know
someone who has escaped from their
neighborhood or who has achieved you
know college degree or got a profession
and I think the teacher could do amazing
things are there so it'll be a much more
it'll be a much more freeform thing
which i think is what a lot of teachers
crave it'll be a lot more personal
connection with students which is what I
think a lot of a teacher's crave why
they went to the profession and I think
you know and this is easy for me to say
and we can debate how likely this is I
think it's going to be a much more it's
it's going to be uh it's going to Italy
effort I guess for lack of a risky
they're gonna get paid better or they
should get paid better that it's going
to be much more it's going to be
professionalized to the point that you
know a master teacher makes as much as a
you know a general practitioner or a
lawyer or an engineer and you know I'll
start with my first data point of why I
think why I think that's possible and
not just an idealistic thing to say is
if you just look at the economics of you
know most school districts they're
spending eight nine ten thousand dollars
per student per year in a room of 25 30
kids you you have 250 300 thousand
dollars per per per classroom and I
don't see any rational reason why the
bulk of that shouldn't be going to the
teacher hey for that any kinda on
something you skipped over so you talked
about personalized missions maybe this
is more long longer term but I don't
think you need to see I don't think you
need to stop at that what if say Google
could say this is a personalized mission
or custom mission if you want to be a
software engineer at Google or if you
want to be a mechanical engineer this is
a set of things you need to know if you
let users or companies or whoever submit
these custom missions for credentials
you might call them for what what people
are look
for to get a job I think that's a pretty
powerful way to change how things work
absolutely you know I think I think the
that's the I mean if I could snap my
fingers and that existed tomorrow I
would do it the you know we're gonna try
I think the way we're thinking about it
is even in something as well understood
as math this idea of personalized
mastery-based having a mission as
opposed to a set kind of lesson plan and
that the you know everyone has a mission
and then they go at their own pace and
it'll give you information how long
until your completion of a mission so
you can pace yourself and things like
that once we understand that better and
I'm hopefully I'm this is we're gonna
launch this next month and hopefully we
understand that really well you know as
we get into the end of the year early
next year I there's nothing I would love
to do more than partner with exactly you
know whether it's Google or Microsoft or
or it's a it's a someone L you know it's
a philosophy professor whoever it might
be is if we can work with them to define
what it means to succeed at some level
of endpoint and if we can measure it
somehow and then try to implement it in
the system and and and and so everyone
can have their own personalized
narrative to to that end point I
completely agree dar she'll we haven't
we had heard from you a little bit you
have a further questions or thoughts
about well kind of playing off of what
you were saying about teacher pay um I
do have a question um what do you think
a solution may be to narrowing the gap
between what is going on in public
versus private education at this time a
lot of inner-city schools do not have
the resources and lack of funding etc
for technology and even time issues in
school due to testing etc and in private
schools they don't really have those
issues so do you have any idea you know
where we could go to cover that gap up a
little yeah it's it's it's you know if
if we could play Emperor there are some
solutions where we could do or we could
just tell but you know obviously these
things become very complex because
there's so many parties that yeah but
you know one thing I will emphasize and
is a lot of the debate and criticism
oftentimes as revolves around the public
school system and in my mind I think
that you know the
private school system in a lot of ways
is has at least as many issues if not
more you know the private school system
they can select for kids if they don't
you know if a kid they don't like them
well you're out you're not here and and
they you know I said eight to ten
thousand dollars per student per year in
public system in the private system it's
often that's where it starts you know
that's like the parochial schools which
are you know the cheapest but if you if
you go up to you know every city the
kind of the fancy private school is
easily twenty or thirty thousand dollars
per student per year and you know they
might have a better student teacher
ratio maybe 15 to 1 20 21 but that's
they have 450 500 thousand dollars per
classroom and they aren't paying their
teachers well either in fact oftentimes
the teachers could get paid less because
in some ways it's easier they don't have
you know it's if a kid's not functioning
well they don't have to be taught there
etcetera etc I you know I I what I would
I'm a big believer in experimentation
what I would love to see is in in in the
public system fact I would like to see
in the public system i'd like to see in
the private system i'd like to see in
the charter system experiments where we
to some degree go back to basics where
we say like let's what does a student
really really really need what is the
most important thing let's make a list
the number one thing that they need is
an amazing teacher and then the number
two thing that they need is like shelter
and you know I actually think it's
better to have an amazing teacher it's
like being rained on then you're you
have shelter and you don't have that
amazing teacher so the number two thing
they need a shelter and climate control
and some type of resources and and I
can't imagine a world where you know for
on Africa spending eight nine ten
thousand dollars and I think we should
be true in the private schools and in
public schools where you know if you
just start with in fact I'd like to I
you know you I'd like to run some
experiments like that locally even for
my own kids where we start a small
school and see if it you know what can
we do with eight nine ten thousand
dollars per student per year but we
start from a very basic notion that the
teacher is the most important element
here and then we need some
infrastructure to support the students
in the teacher so it would be a building
Wi-Fi you know some some computers
pencil paper
art supplies whatever it might be and
then see what we could go from there and
then if we can if we can show real
learning gains along all the dimensions
we're talking about not just the
academic you know right now academic
gets weighted the most so what are the
kids scores and all the rest but also
you know they've created things they get
good peer feedback be able to do drama
and and everything else and they're able
to do that on that type of a budget and
you know if you can then that in theory
could be replicated and it can be
replicated in the public system and and
in the private system but you know here
I don't this is the one where I I
probably you know take take what i have
to say that the biggest grain of salt I
don't know how fast these things change
or don't change you know what what I
feel is you know my somewhat hopeful
view is people you know it's it's it's
always darkest before the dawn a lot of
times when people get most cynical and
they think nothing is ever going to
change nothing's ever going to improve
that's usually that's right before
things start really dramatically
improving so you know yeah I simply a
choice i don't know but at least
intellectually you know this is Ilan
mosque was one of my heroes you know is
what he's doing SpaceX and he's putting
these Rockets up and he wants to put
these Rockets up for like you know a
fraction of the cost of what Rockets
used to cost and and you know he brings
up this idea is like well if you just
look at what a rocket is made of the raw
materials it's like you know it's
one-hundredth of the cost of a rocket
today so why does a rocket cost so much
and so he went through this whole
argument and and I think we have to go
back to the you know back to the same
basics and say well like over ten
thousand dollars a student a year 30
students $300,000 why can't we pay the
teacher half of that 150 thousand
dollars a year they're at parity with
other professions that are equally
important to society like doctors and
lawyers and engineers in fact you know
I'd argue the teachers and a problem
well I don't to make any fight more
lawyers and others and then and then
build from there build from that that
core assumption but I don't I don't know
the answer I don't know if anyone else
here has thoughts on on how that could
change faster in a positive way if I'm
and uh I think this is a one place where
flipping
classroom the whole notion of flipping
the classroom is actually succeeding
because I mean the main there's two main
goals of Education in my eyes which is
number one ensuring that students learn
the material and number two is
cultivating curiosity creativity all
those more abstract concepts that can't
really be taught and in flipping the
classroom you go home do your learning
when you come to class you can work
one-on-one with your teacher you can
work with your peers and focus on really
that human element of teaching that's
not really possible through the internet
or as of now so I think flipping the
classroom is really helping engage
students allow teachers to facilitate
student learning rather than students
adapting to curriculum and really
ensuring that all the girls education of
people may now completely agree
completely agree other thoughts on that
or do we have other questions if not
I'll ask you all some questions I mean
what do y'all what do you think is going
to be the credentials that are going to
matter a 10 years so I'll make it even
more concrete especially especially for
Eric who's about to embark on his
college diploma you know and i'm
assuming take on some you know he's
gonna pay a lot in especially in money
but definitely time as well i'm curious
actually matt neal in particular you're
kind of on the other side of that what
what do you think what do you think is
the value of the college diploma today
and how do you think that that needs to
change oh my gosh i think we'll be out
of time by the time I finish answering
that but that's a very difficult
question and I think most people would
agree that the diploma really doesn't
guarantee what you want the student to
have as far as competencies go and you
talked very briefly about badging and
even though it's an extrinsic motivator
how it might actually be something you
could use as a way of certification of
credentialing throughout the continuum
of learning and to some extent I think I
want the student who people I can in an
accountable way determine that he has or
she has certain competencies rather than
an MCAT score of 30
and you know I know you're starting the
program with double AMC on mcat and so
this is very relevant is we when we
think about physicians we think about at
least nine competencies and medical
knowledge is just one of them and how do
we get at these others how do you
credential in those areas and then keep
track of it so when the student becomes
a resident and then a fellow and then a
practitioner they can transparently be
seen by the patient not by the hospital
that provides the privilege but the
patient who determines which physician
to say and what would you so I mean I
get the sense that you're saying really
you know you're measuring on one
dimension your we might be losing some
incredible physicians who aren't maxing
out the mcat but have some other
incredible traits that right now are not
I mean what what how would you go what
what what what do you think those are I
mean do you think and do you think the
medical community is ready for that type
of a change yeah I think it's starting
no it's a very big ship that we have to
turn around but we are starting what we
moving towards and we have been doing it
at our institution is a portfolio based
assessment and it's competency-based
it's really based on feedback and this
is very challenging because teaching
people how to give useful feedback as
opposed to a rating scale is so critical
and getting the students who have been
trained on I got an A+ to actually seek
feedback which says can you help me
become better i know i'm good at this
what can you tell me and then they are
actually receptive of these feedback and
what we do is make them write a
portfolio a two-page both essay on each
competency at the end of the year and we
don't have grades we don't have tasks
will basically have a review committee
that looks at these essays and
determines if the students met the
standards ready to move on this is a
medical school yeah this is a medical
school or middle school this is it
sounds very good i'm like yeah so come
on join us i love you too is it but here
at that you know any learn apology
I'll part of Kate's water reserve so
yeah we been doing this for about 10
years now and you know you've been kind
of looked upon in the next women but oh
a lot of the programs for creating at
similar to this because most people will
feel this is the right weight but with
we're equal to induce change and I think
that's really the biggest challenge we
have in hot head is a faculty who attend
your who are very busy in medical school
their teen patients doing research and
then on top of it we're asking them to
provide long feedback and accept change
when they believe that difficult
physicians they went to a system that
work why should we change it so it's
difficult yeah absolutely Matt Matt you
have thoughts here about so in the end
though you're still granting a
credential right and that credential is
going to go to us some employer and the
employer wants to know if this is going
to be a good physician how do they know
they don't see these portfolios probably
right they see a credential and the
credential really is just a signal that
means you've jumped through some hoops
say it the value of a Harvard bachelor's
degree for instance is that you got into
Harvard someone else did some narrowing
and you passed and so the employer
thinks oh this is a person that's
already passed through a few hoops and
that's that that's the value that the
employer gets from the credential right
so the question is how do you provide
that value with some other kind of
credential it isn't like how do you get
employers the signal that they really
care about which is will this employee
succeed at their career without needing
the signal that they currently have
which is a bachelor's degree from a
really good institution all right so
that goes back to the I mean patil point
if a competency-based I mean you're
absolutely right you know employers
willing to give the benefit of the doubt
to the Harvard of the Stanford grad
because at age 17 they went through this
ultra competitive filter that is
probably you know or definitely is very
imperfect but they went through it and
so that's a proxy of it and you know do
they know
Harvard did necessarily teach them more
than some other University no they
didn't but if you did have a
competency-based system where you know
pick your domain whether it's it could
be writing it could be critical thinking
it could be it could be a computer
science that if you if you pick the
things that employers cared about or
whoever they say it could be grad
schools it could be whoever could be
future spouses hey well what water I
mean does that sound reasonable to you
Matt yet the question is how do you
break the current system and players
currently rely on this signal and that's
really the only signal they have you
know that could provide them a
credential that is useful to them in
some other way could potentially like
disrupt things but you have to break the
current system somehow no I agree and I
mean my sense is actually it's going to
happen from the employers and I think
you know the field that you're in and I
have a little bit of background in
computer science is probably the first
because it's this really highly
compensated career I mean I'm sitting
here the offices of Google around highly
complicated folks and you know that this
kind of epitomizes this is like the
definition of the 21st century job where
you know they'll complain about not
finding enough folks Khan Academy were
much smaller scale we're always on the
lookout and yeah you know you go to
elite University you will find some
folks who get the one thing you know is
that they probably had a very high s80
score and are you know and wrote a good
college essay and did some other really
interesting thing that got ahead of into
the uh uh you know and the most part
they're very impressive people but what
about the you know what about the the
student who just is a rock star computer
science and flunked you know and flunked
history class you know that he is an
ideal to flunk history class but that we
still might want to find that person
because they could still contribute in
an interesting way and I think that's
where and they're out there and some of
these you know we've we found some folks
who are incredibly brilliant in every
dimension even in history and everything
else but they just weren't into school
and now they can do amazing things so
it's a fascinating it's a fascinating
question actually I'll go to add our
shell because you're in the K through 12
system um I mean what's what
what's your read on all of this huh what
you know what what what how do you think
things are changing what are you hearing
from your peers fellow librarians hello
teachers well I think that things have
changed over the years in in our system
long ago when charter schools first came
about and schools that were different
not the traditional type of schooling
those students were normally looked upon
us oh you're not going to be able to go
to college because you don't have a
traditional high school degree but now
those students are going to college and
they're succeeding in their exceeding
expectations etc so and there are many
schools nowadays that are not
traditional high schools where take the
met for example where you go there and
it is based upon what you're interested
in learning about and what you would
like to be in the future and everything
that you learn is based upon that and
you can take high school classes as well
as college classes to go all told your
high school degree and then these
students are then going on to colleges
and succeeding there so I think it's
more of a roll up so it's already going
that far for you to get into a
university so I think it will keep on
going in that direction and are you just
are you are you in the public system or
are you the private school i'm currently
at a private school but i did teach in
the public system for eight years and
you think that this desire to kind of
rethink things and you know this idea
which I love your these ideas that you
know if you're doing algebra there's
college out of those high school still
algebra get credit for both get a leg up
you know what is you see this happening
in both the private system and the
public system yes um just in different
ways um majority of the innovation in
that area in the public system is in
charter schools I'm in a private
educated private school you can then do
that however you'd like to because it is
your private school that is not bordered
by as many rules etc take an independent
study for example where you're allowed
to follow your own interest and take
online courses and take a MOOC and do
Khan Academy etc anything to boost your
skill in that area which is the
and helped along by a mentor within the
school etc so yes yeah yeah and it
sounds like I mean and what it feels
like and this is my sense to is that as
you said you know 20 30 years ago when
people talked about progressive
education it felt like this kind of
touchy-feely thing no grades are these
kids really going to learn their math
and their signs and one the experiments
gone a lot of wow you know and I think
there's been different degrees of
success um you know I think some of
those schools I mean based on my reading
of it have succeeded because some of
these kids had the type of parents that
Neil was talking about that made sure
that they also got the the core skills
out of the way but what what what I
think it's exciting I mean as you
mentioned you with whether it's MOOCs or
Khan Academy and all the other resources
are out there is that there there's now
tools that you can have a very
progressive education where you're doing
drama and you're making projects you
have a conversation and it's kind of you
know Montessori all the way through
college but you still have these tools
that allow you to learn for like we were
the traditional academic subjects and
but it's still in a very personalized
self-paced way so it's not an either/or
proposition anymore so you can't have
your cake and eat it and eat it too yeah
oh sorry um also I mean you can even go
to your local library and they have
makerspaces set up they're using things
like raspberry pi and of different tools
where you can just use a hands-on
approach to your learning so I mean it's
everywhere now that's interesting I mean
point you're bringing me as a library
what do you think are gonna happen we've
talked about kind of traditional
schooling what he thinks the future of
libraries well I don't think that um
libraries are going away anytime soon
maybe except for funding that's another
story but um I think that libraries are
evolving with the times and they're
becoming places um they're becoming
digital learning commons and things like
that where you can go and you can plug
in and you can use the digital resources
that they have or you can go and do
hands-on projects on whether they're
with computers or technology or anything
else that you're interested in and
they're becoming more places where you
can go and learn not just read a book or
take up a call so yeah you know III
complete it's fun
because I I met some folks from its wits
onian and I read their Misha's tip I had
never read the Smithsonian's Misha's him
and I forgot the exact words but their
mission statement was something like
sharing the knowledge of the world with
everyone it's not something like that so
well that's exactly our mission
statement so it's funny because library
is most of the major library and museum
systems came about in new york public
library has a very similar mission
statement so these museums in these
libraries had these mission statements
you know roughly 150 years ago hundred
years ago and at that time it was really
well how do you share knowledge well
knowledge is in books let me share books
with you how do you share knowledgeable
i can make a museum installation and you
can come see an artifact or something
but I yeah it feels exactly right that
now museums and libraries are going to
be much more seamlessly integrated with
part of the active education process
whether these and they're going to be
this really neat environments of true
multi-age level community engagement
around learning which which could be uh
yeah I think it suits super super duper
exciting definitely that's that seems to
be aimed at these days any any of the
rest of y'all have thoughts of that or
questions about anything or comments
about any and any of what we've talked
about I think that my main question
would be and I think I go everyone who
sent this so far is inducing change is
very difficult and I find that k to 12
educators on the community and elsewhere
are way more receptive to in a weight
and incorporate these technology tools
and they seem to do great in spite of
regulations and state standards and they
still succeed and they really try very
hard I don't know if I'm biased but my
feeling is high red is much different
and more difficult not to crack here and
I don't know what your thoughts are and
how do we go about doing anything there
yeah i guess the grass is always greener
i think i think both sides we've seen
some pretty you know we've seen pockets
of amazing innovation in K through 12
we've seen amazing innovation in in
higher ed
no I am surprised though higher it
hasn't done because higher it is you
know to dart shells point is you know
for it has more flexibility than K
through 12 does and and it is kind of
the last point before going into the you
know the word you know you know some
people will become professors in grad
students but the great bulk of students
are going there you know they want to
get a middle class white collar job
upper middle class job and so and so
yeah I don't know I don't know where
some of that inertias come from although
i think the you know like k-12 my sense
is there's a lot of innovation starting
to happen i think you know the MOOC
trend you know the first stage of the
move trend is replicating a traditional
university course my prediction is the
next wave will be much more of a
competency-based instead of having a
fixed time semester and you know you do
the problem sets in pace with the class
it's going to be much more of a here the
goals you learn I mean hopefully we'll
Khan Academy will do that as well for
college-level material even medical
school level material here's what you
learn anatomy and physiology is the goal
here's how you can get your here's
resources and once those type of things
that exist and those could obviously be
used in the in the in the classroom
where we don't have the intro class with
300 kids and a lecture in the front it
would be 301 people interacting with
each other and doing a project and
having conversations and designing
things and building things so yeah I I
don't know the answer I know if there's
any other thoughts out look together the
other three folks here where innovation
is going to happen faster or slower and
and and why and what what can be done to
catalyze it either in higher education
or k to 12 or even in lifelong learning
corporate graduate school whatever it
might be I think one innovation
especially by utilizing technology to
advance things like online education is
really directing students towards their
resources that they need it whether it's
things like MOOCs Khan Academy extra
help tutor we're having these great like
things online like MOOC consortiums
things like that but I really spreading
the information disseminating it to the
students so they know that they have
these opportunities also in the maybe in
the future I think possibly technology
could be a platform for matching
students with
other students who need help works at
like online tutoring or online education
I know I've probably heard about a few
things like this on Ted calm but but
there's definitely a lot of ways we can
integrate technology and all the
peripherals all the things that we have
available to us with education and
really allow students to succeed and
help them succeed yeah completely agree
Wisconsin yeah I would say with higher
education the thing that will force
universities to innovate is if a student
can get a job without going to unit to
university and I think you'd asset II
like there's some things that are
happening in in computer science that
are promising in that in that regard uh
but i guess i can see in like a medical
field where there are laws about you
have to have these competencies in order
to practice it's a little bit more
tricky but we're a bug is much more
dangerous yeah yeah I guess even a
computer science it can be too buddy the
systems that that match learners with
employers without needing a bachelor's
degree will really drive innovation in
the universe university system because
they will have to innovate to stay alive
and your point is and I think this is an
important one this isn't about you
somehow thinking that university
education is invaluable it's you
thinking that this will be a really good
it'll add a fire for innovation a lot of
fire around competing around well what
is the best path now that there's an
alternate there's there's choice of path
to getting to a good career all of the
different paths creators are going to
have to compete say hey look people on
this path they got a great experience
they got great you know and and and and
yeah I agree that you know I think the
cost probably will come down to and
there'll also be much more diversity in
the offering me hoping that my two
children that are young will not have to
spend so much money on college yes well
you know and that's the thing
something's gotta something's you know
growing five percent faster than the
rate of inflation I think you know
relative I i I'm not that old but you
know when I went to college relative to
when I went to college in real terms
it's almost double and it was even
expensive when I went to college
and for that to double again by the time
you're in my kids you know my kids are
four and two years old that's just it's
just impossible actually there's no
there's no way it can it can no one has
that much money or very few people do so
yes something's going to give I think
with or without online technology
hopefully online technology will just be
kind of a it'll take some of that
pressure off so that there'll be more
room to innovate it etc see very cool
well I think I think we're we're about
out of time I I want to thank everyone
for participating in this this was
really a thought-provoking conversation
and I hope we can do stuff like this in
the future we enjoyed it thoroughly
thank you so much I'll for taking the
time and love talking with everyone on
board here yep and good good good luck
Eric with the college at admissions I
know how that is thank you very much I
mean things like Khan Academy have
really helped me and I hope that we can
further this discussion about education
and technology in the future you should
send in the video of this that will help
us maybe maybe the additional questions
section yes right there you go all right
thank you so I'd see y'all later goodbye
goodbye